exploring ways to accelerate the  creation of a truly digital market  across the eu will be a priority for  ministers in charge of the two-day  competitiveness meeting in brussels next  week  the single digital market is expected to  greatly benefit customers and businesses  within the union  cyber security is a key aspect of this  project  information security is the protection  of networks and systems against human  mistakes natural disasters technical  failures and malicious attacks  following the european commission's  presentation of the 315 billion euro  investment plan for europe ministers  will examine how to simplify rules to  stimulate ventures in the eu  they will also look into how research  innovation and the digital economy can  boost growth and competitiveness  finally they will discuss big data and  what the eu can do to speed up the  transition towards a data driven economy